(soft upbeat music)
- Welcome back everyone.
Our next topic is Canadian
AI Research For Good,
you've heard that phrase a
little bit already today.
As in the last session, we'll look forward
to addressing audience
questions at the end
and I invite you to submit your questions
throughout our discussion
using the Zoom Q&A function.
And so what do we mean when we say
Canadian AI Research For Good?
Well, as many of you know,
the rapid pace of AI
development has already had
a major impact across sectors
and it shows no signs of slowing down.
So how can we as AI
researchers and developers
ensure that these technologies
will benefit everyone
and that the race to deploy
AI will supersede important
principles like privacy,
security, ethics, and equity.
And so audience let's get
you active on the chat.
What do you think?
What are the top three
things that come to mind
when you think of Canadian
AI Research For Good?
Send in your thoughts on the chat.
And so while you're doing that,
I'm excited to welcome some
of the newest members of the
Canada CIFAR AI Chairs program.
Each of our Chairs are
leading important research
in areas that will have a real
positive impact on society.
And so I'll invite Mo, Nidhi,
David, and Rahul to open,
to turn on your cameras
and join me on screen.
And let me introduce my colleagues,
the four of the new
Canada CIFAR AI Chairs.
With us today, we have
Mo Chen, an Amii fellow
and assistant professor at the school
of computing science at
Simon Fraser University.
That's what he's got in his background.
Mo's research specializes
in developing safe robotics.
We have Nidhi Hegde, an Amii fellow
and associate professor at the department
of computing science at
the University of Alberta.
Nidhi is building machine learning methods
that allow technologies to
operate while at the same time
protecting our privacy.
David Rolnick is here.
Hi David, he's a faculty member
at Mila and an assistant professor
at McGill University
school of computer science.
He's also one of the co-founders
of Climate Change AI.
And one of the areas that
his research focuses on
is using AI in the fight
against climate change.
And we have Rahul G. Krishnan.
Rahul is a member of the Vector Institute.
He's an alum of the University of Toronto
and he is returning very shortly to take
up his first faculty position in Canada,
as an assistant professor of
computer science and medicine.
Rahul's research is using machine learning
to understand how disease
progresses over time
using electronic health records.
Thank you to the four
of you for joining us
and congratulations once more.
So let's have a great discussion.
I know our audience will
have lots of questions.
Don't forget to send those
in using the Q&A function.
And we'll start with just
a few structured questions
before we get to the audience.
And so I'll ask in fact each of you
to describe your current research
and tell us what ways your
research can be applied
to deliver positive social benefits.
We're gonna start with Mo.
- Okay yeah, thanks so much,
Elissa for the introduction
and for hosting the event.
So I guess I can talk about
my research for a while
but maybe I'll give the short version.
So my current research
aims to enable robots to
behave safely and naturally among people.
So we work on topics such as
human intending prints,
collision avoidance
for mobile robots,
multi-agent coordination.
So our techniques can be
applied to indoor places
like schools and stores
and also outdoors as well.
So I think the key here is to be safe,
for robots to be safe, but still useful.
So of course a robot
can be completely safe
it, if it operates far from
people or a for example, a car
a self-driving car is just
staying parked, right?
But we need to like to
go further than that.
We need to walk the fine line
between interacting closely with people
and still staying safe and
hopefully trust it eventually.
- Yeah, so that robots can
eventually be our partners in
much of the work that we do right?
- Right, right.
Yeah, yes, so maybe getting
a little bit more technical.
So our methodology
involves control theory,
reinforcement learning computer vision.
So for example, we try to adapt
safety verification algorithms
that are used in the aerospace
to product environments on the ground.
We also try to combine classical
optimization techniques
with data-driven learning based methods.
So we have several examples of that.
one of them I like to
bring up is like, we try to
use learning based methods to
do a higher level planning.
Like where am I should
go next at a high level?
And then the details of
how to get there safely
can be taken care of by some
of these classical algorithms.
Yeah, so I guess you asked the
second part of the question
positive societal benefits?
Autonomous robots today
are often used in controlled
environments like warehouses
or maybe in the absence of other agents
like robot Watson people.
So I, hopefully my research will allow us,
well our robots, to interact
with people more closely,
for applications such as like maybe a
robot assistant, delivery
vehicles, autonomous cars.
And for example, in one project
we put a collision
avoidance system on robots
and then we have students
try to drive a robot
into a wall or into obstacles
in unknown environments
in the wild they try, but they
fail to cause a collision.
So that's a, that's a
really cool experiment.
And we are, we're also working
on something called a follow ahead project
where a robot tries to autonomously
stay in front of a person.
So kind of imagine you
have a shopping cart
but instead of you pushing a shopping cart
it's kind of just pushing
itself in front of you.
So I think I'll stop here.
- Those are some, some great examples
of fun graduate research
projects going on in your lab.
Thanks for sharing those.
Nidhi over to you, tell
us about your research
and how it's driving towards delivering
positive benefits for society.
- Yeah, hi, Elissa thank
you for the introduction
and for hosting this
very interesting event.
So my current research
is in looking at privacy
and fairness in machine learning.
So what I'm interested in is looking at
real practical problems
where some of the current
privacy preserving methods
don't really fit very well,
and what are the fundamentals
that we need to work
on in order to get that working?
So for example, a lot
of data is structured.
For example, the data that
you're producing when you're
on social networks, which means, you know
a data point does not
necessarily independent
of the other data points
there's related somehow,
and this could be for example,
in the structure of a graph.
If we have apply standard
privacy preserving methods
then this doesn't scale well to the size.
So you can, we can't look
at large data sets anymore.
The noise, the privacy
costs that you would need
and the compute power you would need
would quickly be prohibitive.
So I'm looking at that kind of question.
Another example is let's
say different partners
in machine learning and
AI want to share data,
but you know, we don't
want to share actual data
because of privacy concerns.
So we might want to
create synthetic data sets
and share those.
But synthetic data sets are
not private by themselves.
So we need to do something
else to make them private.
There are some methods out there
but they're very specific
to certain tasks.
So how can we generalize this?
And another interesting problem is
how does privacy interplay with fairness?
Can we have both in a particular
machine learning model?
Some preliminary work has shown
that it's not possible for
all conditions to have both.
So how do we make sure,
can we devise new algorithms
that make sure that
we can have a privacy preserving
outcome that is also fair?
- Your research really sort
of reminds me that, you know,
we need to strike such a
fine balance between privacy
and data access in order
to be able to do the
machine learning research
that we've been talking about today.
Of course we need researchers,
need access to data
so that's why your work is so critical.
Any other thoughts on the social benefits?
- Yeah, so obviously, you
know, by the definition
of the problems I'm
working at, it has obvious
social benefits, you
know, machine learning AI
really impacts every part of our lives.
So anywhere that we can
limit damage or harm
like privacy breaches or
biased outcomes that lead
to decisions that impact
people in their daily lives
for instance is important.
So, you know, this type of
work has a clear end goal,
which is to safeguard
People from, you know,
potential outcomes.
- And impacts on all of us as individuals.
Yeah, great.
Thank you very much.
Rahul, over to you, tell
us about your research
and it's opportunity for
positive social benefits.
- Thanks so much.
So I, thank you again for
organizing this wonderful
set of talks and panels, my own research,
maybe I'll start with a
bit of historical context.
And so over the last three decades
there has been an increasing realization
that a lot of the healthcare data
that's been digitized by
hospitals as they went to record
how patients interacted
with the healthcare system
can be of use beyond the original intent
that these records were created for.
So originally a lot of
these healthcare records
were created for bookkeeping
and for billing purposes
across North America.
And in the last few decades
what we've seen is that
people have been interested
in understanding how
the patterns that live
within these data can be used
for the creation of
machine learning models
to automate clinically meaningful tasks.
And so why might that be interesting?
Well, for one, we know
that access to health care
and the quality of healthcare access
that people do have is
not equally distributed.
So part of the pitch for
this line of work is to
help transfer some of the
knowledge that may exist
in high resource settings
to low resource settings
via the use of predictive
models and machine learning.
And so more broadly, my work
lies at this intersection
of machine learning and
healthcare, and within it
I do research both in applied areas
as well as more methodological areas.
And so to give two concrete examples
of some of the applied work
that I do, one is on this idea
of patient risk
stratification, which is to say
can we use algorithms and models
for machine learning to find
patterns and patient data
and predict whether or not
they will have adverse
outcomes in the future.
Now at the outset, this looks
like a fairly standard predictive problem,
but I think once you delve into it
you begin to understand some
of the nuances that exist,
because healthcare data is not as clean
as some of the data that exists
and is commonly used in machine learning.
There's many potential biases
that want us to navigate
in order to ensure
that the underlying model
that's being learned is a true
and good model of a, a
faithful model rather,
of the outcome that one
cares about predicting.
The second example is that
of disease progression,
which is to say doctors
often collect large cohorts
of patients that course who all suffer
from a common disease.
And so in the context of that problem
one interesting question,
that is how can we
use this data to
understand diseases better?
Which is to say does
diabetes have predictable
patterns of evolution
within the human population?
And if we were able to
use machine learning to
discover those predictable
patterns of evolution
can those then lead doctors to ask new
and interesting hypothesis
about how to treat the disease better?
So really using machine learning
as a tool for hypothesis discovery.
And what I found during the
course of my own research
is the fact that these problems
are often require new machine
learning advances as well
in order to be able to
tackle them effectively.
So in the past, I've
worked on new algorithms
for probabilistic inference
and nonlinear models,
as well as new techniques to
reduce the sample complexity
or rather to reduce how data
hungry these models are.
Because often in healthcare,
one does not always have access
to millions and millions of samples
in order to learn these
machine learning models.
So in the future, I'm
interested in thinking
about how to make use of some
of the advances that we
have in causal inference
to build automated clinical
decision making support tools,
as well as thinking
about some of the nuances
of deploying machine
learning models in hospitals,
how do we tackle issues
like the fact that our distribution
of people changes over time?
It's not the same people
going into the hospital
and that has downstream
effects on how well
any deployed machine
learning algorithm performs.
And finally, to tackle this question
that you asked of societal benefit.
I think there's a few ways
in which this broad area
can deliver some form
of societal benefit.
And this is particularly
true in the case of Canada
where there's a, where the
provincial systems are set up
in a way to provide
healthcare for everyone.
And so one is in the
context of early prediction
or risk stratification
for chronic diseases.
There are certain diseases
where if you were to
predict early that a patient
is at risk for continuing
on to develop that disease,
there may be interventions
that one can take and
prevent the development
of chronic versions of that
disease in that patient.
And so diabetes is one
simple example of it, where
if a patient is put on a
diet and exercise regimen
prior to the development
of chronic diabetes
they can often stave off some of
the comorbidities that are
associated with that disease.
And so this is a case
where predictive models
can lead to interventions,
which can then lead to
better public health outcomes
both from a cost perspective,
but more importantly
from a human health perspective.
The second is in the context of developing
these predictive models and deploying them
in some of the lower
resource settings where,
and in doing so reduce
some of the inequality
that exists in access to healthcare.
So I'll conclude with that
and I hope I answered
some of the key questions
that you asked.
- Good, thank you for going
into your areas of interest
and some of the issues
surrounding AI for health research
and innovation in detail, you know,
it's an area I think that we
have tremendous opportunity
in Canada to really play a
leadership role in understanding,
you know, how AI and machine learning
can be applied within
Canada's healthcare systems
the many multiple systems we have
in each of our provinces and territories,
but we have such great
expertise in this country
and I think a lot of will
to think really critically
about deploying AI within
our health systems,
and a huge part of what we have to do is,
work with citizens and
patients and the public
to help them to understand
what the benefits are
of bringing AI into our systems.
And I think there are multiple.
So thank you for your work on this topic.
David, last but not least, your
work is really fascinating.
Tell us about your research
and its a positive impact on society.
- Thank you so much, it's
a pleasure to be here.
I work on the applications
of AI to climate change.
So helping society to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
and also respond to the
effects of climate change.
And that means applications in areas
like energy, and
transportation, buildings,
and urban planning, sustainable
forestry and agriculture,
ecology, and disaster response.
Now climate change is a huge
and multifaceted problem
and AI is not going to solve it.
It's not a silver bullet here,
but it can be a powerful tool
for particular pro particular problems.
For example, AI can help
distill large amounts
of information to help
policymakers make decisions.
For example, by using satellite imagery,
to automatically monitor
greenhouse gas emissions,
or land use, or monitor ecosystem change.
It can also help optimize
complicated systems.
So for example, reducing
the energy required to heat
and cool a building, or
improving the efficiency
of freight transportation
networks, can improve forecasting
for example of agricultural
productivity or food insecurity.
And it can also accelerate the process
of scientific discovery itself
by speeding up the search
for new materials, like those in batteries
or in photovoltaics.
If you're interested in
the full space of where
AI can be helpful in climate
change, we actually put
out a hundred page paper
with recommendations
that's designed to help guide
this field moving forward
but let's dive into an example
from my research group.
One of the challenges to using
more solar and wind power
is that the sources of power
vary from moment to moment,
depending upon whether the sun is shining
or the wind is blowing.
That means it's really
difficult to control
an electrical grid with lots of renewables
because the available
supply of electricity
is always changing.
So basically grid operators need to solve
a large non-convex optimization problem.
It's called AC Optimal Power Flow,
or AC-OPF in order to manage the grid.
The existing ways to
do this are very slow.
The problem actually needs to
be solved every few minutes
if you have a lot of
solar and wind energy.
So in practice people have
been radically simplifying
AC-OPF in order to make it more tractable
and these solutions
are just not very good.
My group just released a
deep learning algorithm
that makes it possible to
good and fast solutions,
to AC-OPF by encoding the constraints
and the problem state
statement, essentially
providing a guarantee that
the lights won't go out,
that it will satisfy the constraints
from the electrical grid.
And previous deep learning
algorithms on electrical grids
couldn't do that, which as you can imagine
many people much less likely to apply them
because, you know, if
you're a grid operator
you really want to make
sure the lights don't go.
So our approach actually
not only works for AC-OPF,
but it also works
for big non-conductive
optimization problems in general.
So it's very broadly useful.
Some of the other projects in my group
are semi-supervised
remote sensing approaches
for monitoring biodiversity
and ecological change,
and fast approximate simulations
of atmospheric physics
to integrate into large
weather and climate models.
The existing models are great,
but key components of them
like as with the electrical
grid can be very slow
and machine learning
approximations can speed
some of those components up.
Really a key aspect of
our work across problems
and application domains
is close collaboration
with domain experts and other stakeholders
like the Montreal Insectarium,
and Environment and Climate Change Canada,
to ensure that the work is guided
by the societal benefits
and is deployed impactfully.
And as Elissa mentioned, I'm
also co-founder and chair
of the Climate Change AI
initiative, which facilitates work
at this intersection of climate
change and machine learning.
And we cultivate the global network
of researchers in the States,
we organize workshops
and advise stakeholders
and put out grants and other resources.
- Great, thank you, David.
You know, as I was listening
and thinking about all
of you and your research,
one of the things that
struck me and David noted it
specifically is this highly
multidisciplinary, right?
So you all, because you want to apply
your machine learning tools
and algorithms and approaches
to real-world scenarios,
of course you have to work
with people with diverse expertise.
And so that I think lends a
real richness to your research
and real opportunities to engage
scientists and researchers
outside of computer science
in the application of AI.
It's very exciting.
And then the other
thing that struck me too
is that there are huge
policy questions related
to all of your work as well, too.
And so there's another you
know huge group of stakeholders
that we have the opportunity to work with
and share and talk about our research
so that they can become more involved
and understand the
challenges and opportunities
of applying machine learning
to some of these policy questions as well.
Its great stuff, guys.
Okay, so that, I'll go back to my script
and stick to the questions
for a few minutes.
So all of you are taking up
your first faculty position
in Canada, which is it's fabulous,
we're so happy to have you.
Can you tell us each why
did you choose Canada
and the AI Institute that
you're affiliated with
as the right place for you
to be pursuing your research?
And I'm gonna start with David on this.
- Sure, so I don't think I
need to convince this audience
that Canada is at the
forefront of innovation in AI.
I'm really thrilled to a part
of the CIFAR AI community
both at Mila and across Canada.
One of the things that I
really love about this program
is that it represents
as Elissa was indicating
really an exceptional opportunity
for synergy between research,
industry, and policy
which is essential for
enabling impactful AI work
on topics like climate
change and many other topics.
Innovation in AI doesn't
exist in isolation.
It should be driven by problems
of relevance to society
and it should be developed
in conjunction with the
various relevant stakeholders.
So those stakeholders can
include researchers in other
fields like energy agriculture
or ecology in my case,
but also the companies
that are often involved
in implementing AI innovations,
and the policy makers who've
helped shape the overall space
and very importantly, end
users, people and communities
and CIFAR represents an
opportunity for communication
between many different voices.
This is not just the way to build tools
that are most beneficial for society,
but it's also the way to drive
breakthroughs in AI itself.
So areas of cutting edge AI research
like hybrid physical
models and interpretability
are spurred on by the
needs of end stakeholders
to incorporate known system
constraints in this case
or to better understand how
the algorithm is working
these are the needs and
that leads to innovation.
So the right kind of research ecosystem
really benefits everybody.
- That's great, thank you.
Nidhi, what about you?
Why did you choose Edmonton and Amii?
- Well, actually I'm
originally from Edmonton
and I was away for many years.
This is my first faculty
position, but I've been working
for about 18, 19 years
in industry research.
And most of it about 17
of those years in France.
So this was a great opportunity
for me to not only come back
to Canada, but to Edmonton,
and to participate in this
wonderful ecosystem we have here.
You know, I echo what David
himself said here about CIFAR
having giving us this
opportunity to make these
short connections between
different parts of the country
through Amii, Mila and Vector,
you know, which gives us
you know a wide range of
people we can collaborate with
and topics like the one that
I'm working on, you know
it's really important to
connect with, you know
different disciplines,
researchers, you know
privacy impacts health, for example,
and it impacts you know, other services
like recommend assistance.
So this is a great opportunity
to be able to connect
with people of different disciplines
and being in this academic environment,
I'm also able to connect
with other disciplines
like law, and sociology,
and business, for example
where we are starting to see a
lot of impacts of AI as well.
- Absolutely that's again,
that multidisciplinary
collaboration is really
what's key to driving these technologies
and making sure that they're implemented
in a way that's really
responsible and effective.
And so while we're talking
about responsible AI
and that's a phrase that we
throw out a lot in Canada
you heard it quite a bit
this morning from speakers,
Rahul and Mo let's talk about
your areas of application.
You know, what are some of
the important considerations
that you think about or that
the community thinks about
in health, or in robotics,
when it comes to ensuring
that your ML approaches are implemented
in a way that is responsible?
How about we'll start with Rahul?
- Absolutely, I think
the area of health care
is one where you cannot
blindly you walk in
and make the assumption that
any black box machine learning
algorithm will perform well.
And so this is particularly
true for two reasons.
One, there exists societal
biases that manifests in the data
that what these algorithms are trained on,
and the naive application
of these algorithms
might simply amplify the existing biases.
Two knowing what is
relevant for the prediction
task at hand is often
not something that most
machine learning practitioners
will be well-versed about.
And furthermore, what is
relevant might simply change
across the different
contexts that the model
may be considered to be applied in.
So what's relevant in hospital one
for predicting a patient outcome,
may simply not be
relevant in hospital two,
because the way they do things
in terms of their processes
is fundamentally different.
So I think in the context of healthcare,
there's two key considerations
for thinking about responsibly
I think important to start with at least,
and there's many, many more.
And so the first is working
with domain experts.
I think there's absolutely
no substitute for working
with a domain expert in
a area like healthcare
because he or she is the one who's worked
with the data every day of their career.
And they arguably know
about any limitations
that the data may have and
can think through the impacts
of those limitations on
the downstream performance
of any model that's being developed.
And so the second key
consideration I'd say is
monitoring the performance of the model
in any deployed solution.
So I think, you know
this notion of responsible
AI is not, it's not a one-off
it doesn't stop when the
model is done training.
It's a sort of a commitment
to continue to see how the model
performs in a live scenario
and monitor it for
unintended consequences.
And what I wanna point out here is
that these unintended
consequences need not be
from what the model is predicting alone.
They could be much bigger
implied consequences that come about
as the model is used in practice.
So the ground that in a concrete example,
you can think of a
prediction tool that say
predicts whether or not a
patient should be recommended
for a second opinion for in
the context of say a disease.
And so if this model
is really, really good
at this prediction task,
what essentially happens is
that you have a much
larger volume of people
who are now going to
doctors and specialists
for second opinions, but we
have a finite set of resources,
our finite set of specialists,
who may not have the capacity
to handle that volume.
And so this is an unintended consequence
not due to the failure of the model,
but rather due to the systemic nature
of the healthcare system that
this model is deployed in.
And so I I'd say that, like,
it's important to think
about both the micro and
the macro scale consequences
of deployed solutions or
machine learning In this context
- Yeah, absolutely.
And both of those examples
that you gave, remind me of
especially in a healthcare
context, this idea of, you know
the humans in the loop, right?
Like, so keeping the clinicians very close
to the development of the
machine learning algorithms
and tools that are being deployed,
but then, you know, we as practitioners
following the evolution of our models
as they are deployed and
out there in the world.
So that's great.
How about you Mo, tell us about, you know,
the considerations around responsible AI
when we're talking about robotics.
- Yeah, in fact, I
mean, even though health
and robotics says
it sounds like kind of different areas,
I actually think that
there's a lot in common.
So one of the things that we
really worry about is like
if an AI makes a error in judgment,
it's not just some misclassified image,
but in both robotics and
health, there's, I mean,
there's immediate physical
consequences to people.
So of course I think safety
and sort of reliability
of the systems is
really, really important.
And I think it's actually
one of the bottlenecks
that we need to get through,
in order to kind of advance
the field of robotics
in everyday life.
I think a lot of these
keywords I'm gonna mention
you probably have heard like
interpretability, right?
I think robots will make mistakes
and hopefully not too many,
but they will make some mistakes.
And when they do, we
need to understand why
and systematically kind of,
sort of improve the areas
that they are weak at.
I think one, one thing that
I am pretty interested in
is to have robots realize
when they should be unsure
of themselves.
So if you have like a,
if you have a driver
let's say a human driver
or a human doctor, right?
Especially during training, they...
Well, training is now kind
of an overloaded term now.
So what people know
that people know when
they should be unsure
and maybe when they
should ask help, right?
This is something that I
don't really think robots
are, can do yet.
And hopefully they will
be able to do this later.
One thing that is also
very important for robotics
is how can we learn safely, right?
One of the ways I'm learning
safely is in simulation.
And so can we develop
methods that can robustly
transfer behavior, learned in
simulation to the real world?
So this is a very active area of research.
So in the end, I think one of
the really more complex things
that I wanna consider
is really people's past.
So suppose we make these
systems very technically robust,
technically speaking, they are
very, very, let's say safe.
Will people still trust them, right?
A lot of people, a lot of
times we've seen user studies
where the robot is behaving optimally,
but people feel that, feel
that the robot is acting weird.
And even though the robot
is doing probably better
than humans, humans don't
necessarily trust the robots.
So in terms of trust,
I think it's a very very typical topic.
I think one thing that we
would have to do as a community
is to make sure we
educate everyone, right?
Not just the students,
but the entire community
including people who have already
been working in AI, right?
We need to understand we can choose to be,
we can choose to trust
AI, or maybe be skeptical,
but the trust or skepticism,
it needs to be informed.
And I think as a community
this is a very important
thing in the long-term.
- Yeah, and any thoughts Mo
on how we should do that?
You know, you're talking specifically,
I think about the research community,
I and my colleagues at CIFAR
had been thinking about
the public and engaging
the public around AI.
Do you think we have to do both?
- Well, obviously I'm kind of
focused more on the education
of students, like the
graduate students, as well as
the undergraduates, just
kinda running into the
maybe like advice for students.
I think ...
- Go ahead.
- I would say like, we need
to learn the fundamentals
properly.
There are no shortcuts, right?
So a lot of times when we think of AI,
we think of perhaps
downloading some toolbox
that is, that makes doing
research convenient,
but those should be more
like a jumpstart, right?
There's still no shortcut
in learning the math,
learning the fundamentals,
and Canada being one of the places
where we really value
fundamental research,
this is especially important.
And I would say this
extends not beyond students,
this is also for everyone involved.
I've talked to many of my
friends who are actually
well-educated and they are aware of AI,
but I would say that in general,
I really hope to see people understand
the fundamental fundamentals
a little bit more.
- Great.
- And maybe, yeah.
Maybe more events like this,
in fact, that could help.
- Yeah, that's part of why we
do it, for sure, absolutely.
Okay, I'm gonna take a few
questions from the audience now.
We've had lots of great questions come in
and I want to share one with you
that's particularly been up-voted
by a number of individuals
and people are putting their
thumbs up for this one.
It's coming in from the Ashwell,.
So it's, you know, it's,
it's a loaded question.
What should happen to make sure
AI for social good
applications are developed
even when the profit motive
is not sufficient to motivate companies?
So, you know, how do we
make sure that, you know
AI for Good applications
are really a priority
for us as a research community,
a research and innovation
community when the private sector
and their profit motive is not,
is not high enough for
them to be involved.
Thoughts on, on that balance.
Anybody wanna chip?
- Well,
I'd like to start by saying
it helps to have a monetary
incentive obviously,
but when that isn't there,
I think in the research
community can fairly easily
be convinced that this is an
important problem to look at.
I think the community
that needs to be convinced
is the industry, the business,
and the general public.
Sometimes they're just not
aware and possibly even,
I mean I believe in a
multi-pronged approach
so possibly even, sort of the
regulatory or policy bodies.
One, you know, analogy I like to use is,
you know, industries like telecom,
where I worked for many
years ago have standards
that their protocols must abide by.
And that's important for the communication
but for areas where you don't need that,
you still have certain guidelines.
Like many years ago
the consumer protection
agencies were very important
and their work led to
things like having labels
on clothing irons that say
don't iron while you're
wearing your clothes.
So, and you know, no one's saying
that clothing iron shouldn't be produced
and shouldn't exist,
but the harm that can be
produced from it was recognized.
So in the same way, I think
for AI products and services,
I think we all agree that
they're very important
and impactful, but the harm
that they may result in
is not properly recognized.
And so maybe, you know,
we need something like,
something like these
consumer protection agencies
that allow people to be educated
about the harms and how
they can be safeguarded.
So if the people are then aware of this
then they can push using their, you know,
where they spend their money on,
they can push the industry or businesses
in certain directions.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'm reminded again, to
go back to healthcare,
where it's, you know a highly
regulated sector in Canada
and the US and both the
FDA and health Canada,
you know, actively and carefully examine
machine applications very closely
before they're implemented
within, you know,
within health systems and
they are, it's happening,
and so that's, that's
definitely the right direction.
Anything else
on public private sector?
- Hey can I?
- Go ahead, Dave.
- I can step in a bit.
So I think that one
component is using our voices
not necessarily in a research capacity,
but in the capacity of thought leaders
to add to the conversation
about what best policies
and best practices are.
we have, we have leadership roles
that don't involve necessarily
coming up with a new algorithm.
People, it is important for the community
to use its voice in that way.
And then I think another component of this
and then that does involve
informing stakeholders
of what the capabilities of systems are
and what they can do to best incentivize,
incentivize meaningful impact.
And that also means informing
ourselves what that means.
But I think another
component is remembering
that research needs to be
scoped with impact in mind
from the get-go.
It's not a question of
I wrote a great paper
with a great project,
and now I'm going to look for
a way to make it impactful.
Oh, wait, I don't see a path to impact.
This is why one should work
with stakeholders from,
from like the initial scoping of a project
and the development of the project,
in addition to the
deployment of the project,
because once you get to deployment
you haven't scoped it
together with the people
who will ultimately be using it,
it's too late.
There are ton of opportunities
where the incentives are aligned right now
and making sure that one
is working with the people
who will be deploying your
projects can help you ensure
you are working in a space
where you will be able to
have the impacts that you want.
- That's great, David, thank you for that.
And it is actually your response speaks
to one of the other questions that came in
that reads "What do you see as the role of
individual researchers
versus the organization
or external players like governments,
in ensuring that AI is used
in socially beneficial ways."
So I wanted sort of share that one
with the other members of the panel.
What do you see as your role
as individual researchers in
you know, being a voice
around responsible use of AI?
Anybody?
- Yeah, I can, I can chime in on this.
I think as individual researchers,
a, we serve two roles.
One is education, which
is educating students
be undergraduate or the graduate level,
and teaching them to
create new algorithms,
and machine learning, and robotics,
and healthcare, and climate science.
And it's, I think that
educational component of it
is a big part of the role that we can play
in order to make sure that
the effort that we put in
is multiplied by the
students who learned from us.
And as long as we in, incorporate in them
a sense of responsibility,
a sense of values,
and in how to ensure
that these applications
are used responsibly,
I think that's one of
the most impactful ways
that we can help,
because ultimately that's who
we spend a lot of time with,
the students.
The second way is I
think I agree with David
is having our voices heard
in a variety of different scenarios,
and ensuring that the ideas we put forth
are ones that are consistent
with these notions of safety
and responsibility and responsibly
using the more technical
approaches that we develop.
- Great, thank you.
Okay, we're, I've got two
minutes left on the clock,
or maybe even less.
So we're gonna switch to
sort of final thoughts
and I'd love to just
have each of you give us
in sort of 30 seconds, let's
call it 20 seconds or less.
Tell us, you know, your best
advice for graduate students
interested in your particular
area of machine learning.
What should they be doing now to prepare
for their future careers
in academia and industry.
Mo we'll start with you.
- Yeah, as I mentioned earlier,
we need to learn the
fundamentals properly, right?
No short cuts, we need to, in robotics
we need theory, how the
theory translates to code,
and how code translates to robots moving
in the physical world, right?
And don't be afraid to collaborate
with other faculty members
other than your supervisor
and internships are great.
So just to get all the expertise,
all the all the expertise
wherever you can get.
- That's great, thank you.
Nidhi, your best advice
for graduate students?
- So I think my topic is
necessarily multidisciplinary
and necessarily has a clear and
immediate impact on society.
So I would suggest that
they make themselves aware
of actual, real impacts, like
real examples that, you know
journalists have investigated
on where privacy breech
has occurred, or where fairness
or bias questions arise.
I think that's important.
And also second what most said,
which is understanding the fundamentals
because things like privacy and fairness
you know, they're,
sometimes they're even hard
to intuitively say what they mean to us,
and they may be even harder
in a mathematical way
to define what they are,
and that's really important.
Do we know, we need to be
rigorous about these definitions
and about how we derive
these in order to then
create algorithms that, that
mitigate these problems.
And so the fundamentals are
important and multidisciplinary
you know, don't be afraid to talk to
people in law, or in philosophy,
to get a more well-rounded understanding.
- Absolutely, Rahul over to you.
Best advice for grad students.
- Yeah, I think there's
two pieces of advice
that I would really have.
I would echo most thoughts on
and focus on foundational knowledge.
So when you think about classes,
don't think of them as
I wanna learn the most
advanced topic first,
I think it's much, it's
very much in your interest
to pick the more foundational topics
on the algebra, optimization,
stochastic processes,
and really this is because
machine learning is fundamentally
just a melting pot of
different sub-disciplines,
and it has always been that way.
And so being very good and
having strong foundations
is crucial to any future
success in the sub-area.
And the second thing that I'd say is in
at least what I found when
I was studying is the fact
that I think patterns
are sort of universal.
And I think if you learn to
recognize patterns that exist
in different classes that you're taking,
and have a conceptual framework
by which you can learn to manipulate them,
that's an incredible skill to have,
because at the end of the day,
a lot of ideas are rediscovered and reused
in different sub-fields and
being able to flexibly move
within fields and describe how
one idea relates to another
in a completely separate arena,
it will only strengthen
sort of the mental models
you have of the world
and ultimately lead to
more interesting kinds of research ideas.
- Great advice, David, last word to you.
- Yeah, so to echo what
other people have said.
learn the fundamentals, but
not just machine learning,
learn the fundamentals of whatever areas
you're looking to integrate
with machine learning,
and go in with humility.
Recognize that each of these
other areas of application
has decades or centuries
of great work in it.
And machine learning is
not suddenly gonna solve
all those problems,
or if it does solve
some of those problems,
it's going to do that only
by integrating with all of
that existing knowledge,
and by really carefully
working with people
who are expert in those areas.
And if you want to have any
impact, start from the problem,
whether it's a theoretical
or an applied problem,
start from the problem
and let the tools that you use
evolve to match the problem.
Don't go in assuming that the,
the fanciest newest tools are best.
And then paradoxically
often that is actually
what will lead to foundational innovation.
That is what will lead
to the breakthroughs in
from an algorithmic perspective too,
is really being driven
by what people need.
- This is great advice
and it's been such a
fabulous conversation.
I hate to have to cut it off
but I'm afraid that is all
the time we have for today.
So thanks so much to all of
you, all of our panelists
for sharing their insights
and experience experiences.
We're really thrilled to have
you as part of the candidacy
for AI Chairs program and
thanks to the audience
for great questions and
discussion over the chat.
It's been fantastic.
(soft upbeat music)